good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast I'm so excited because
it's hump day we are joined by I was
like really Shook at how many people
were so excited for you to be here oh my
God the fans the fans your last episode
oh sorry it's Joey camasto hello
your last episode where you told the
story about you [__] your pants
might be it might be in the toast Hall
of Fame oh my God what an honor do you
have any other have you [__] your pants
recently
um no I haven't [__] my pants or
anything but I'm sure there's something
else that's been wild I'm sure
embarrassing you've been booked and busy
she is she's booked in busy I'm uh I've
been you know just working around trying
to make that coin trying to get that
that Austria Rich a shop you literally
are a Barstool star yeah I know you are
host of the out and about podcast
correct you still host it's happening
with Snooki yes which has been really an
OG yeah for many many moons many many
almost eight years now I think wow even
know what it was when they first started
how do you juggle it all Joey
um I just drank a lot and you know take
naps I take a nap every day at four
o'clock like adrenal medley really yeah
how long usually about two hours holy
[__] that's really long yeah but then I
wake up and I'm like you know then I can
get my things up and then I have to put
myself down right like like a
thoroughbred with pills so you could
take uppers and downers I take well I
don't take uppers anymore I take uppers
when I go out to stay up but like um you
know just during the work days you know
I put what I could put in in the work
day and then you know I take some time
for myself and what puts you down these
days uh just regular Xanax but I also do
like a Unisom if I'm from overseas I
can't get I can't the good stuff I will
take a Unisom I'll take two a Unisom is
nice I was also on the CVS brand name
Hills for a long time oh like the
generic brands brand ones yeah and how
did they work they were good I like
those as well those are good if you're
on a bargain Queen are you a bargain
Queen no you're rich these days but yeah
I'm not I'm still not a bargain queen
I'm spending so much money it's like
ridiculous are you now you have this
newfound like life you know I think for
a really long time you were kind of like
a sidekick almost is that weird to say I
don't know oh you were doing you know
Snooki's podcast I like to say I was
living in the shadow of snooky's poof
you were living in the shadow of Snooki
that's gonna kill my Memoir love that
it's called Joey get out of the shot
living my life living the shadow of
suitcase poof it's literally amazing but
you were always the star you really were
I feel very not to make everything about
me I feel like I always saw it you know
you've been on the toast your first
toast was like back in the day yeah and
before we both had chin lipo right yes
and you are I've always been a star but
I'm so glad everyone's seeing it now
tell me about life at Barstool I never
would have pictured you at Barstool but
let me just say it's super hey Miss
Portnoy Mr oh my God he's so annoyed
with me um it's such it's it's kind of
like a dream coming true it's like I
always wanted an environment where I
could just be myself and like you know
when you had a regular job like did you
ever have a real job I did okay
remembering David regular job and just
[__] around all day doing things that
are funny practical jokes in the office
faxing your friends pictures of your
[__] and nobody appreciates you yeah
no one appreciate it you're really just
doing your the most at your job which
you're meant to be doing yeah it's
almost like dress for the job you want
not the one you have something I just
did that job I wanted but not at the job
right right so I'd be like you know in
an office but I'd be like you know
performing and faxing my ass to people
right right so now I just could do that
in a professional setting what is the HR
situation at Barstool because I feel
like it's they have one they do they
have one and but it's getting more and
more like you know stricter now because
we just got bought by Penn National
games right
um but even before that they they have
like the they have a lot like you know
they signed you up but also when you're
signing on the papers it says like you
know be aware that you will be um
exposed to lewd you know lewd situations
and things like that there will be foul
language there will be this you kind of
know ahead what time what you're getting
in for so you're not like you know you
know a Christian woman's not to go
they're buttoned up and then I run
around I'm sorry about you yeah being
you know it's too lewd for you but have
you crossed the line like I'm sure I
have but you have you gotten in trouble
not yet knock knock on wood I feel like
they love you they know what they have
with you yeah but you have to be careful
I mean I do like you know I could have a
slip of the tongue next thing you know
fired well a certain group of people
fired yeah yeah look at randomly
um but I you know I certainly fun to let
me be yourselves this really actually
when they hire you they're like all
right go out and have fun make make good
stuff and just be yourself so I've kind
of been doing that so we've been doing
great on the podcast I'm doing a little
reality show called working girls it's
basically like
um it's like simple life but with two
unhinged gays love love love and is that
you and your co-host and co-host Trish
Trish
um so we're doing that we're actually
having an event tomorrow for uh for the
for the big for the big um our big
episode we're having and you know pride
month which is pride month the only
reason you're here I've decided to
tokenize you I had a lesbian yesterday
oh who was that Taylor Striker oh she's
coming on my pockets this week she's the
best yes
Yankee Swap yeah I love that
um I feel like you're the type of Queen
who like hates pride month am I right
about that you do right so not because
I'm not because I'm that type of Queen
I'm just old I've shaken a Tail Feather
with with the Dyke lesbians on the pier
yeah do you know what I mean I do know
they like to fight at the pride parade
do they oh my God so everyone says
what's Pride like it's really just a
bunch of Butch lesbians getting in fist
fights interesting and us you know and
drunk engaged like pill swapping [__]
popping [__] popping yeah all that I
would love to experience Pride Through
Your Eyes well well you can because I'm
going to be having a float a double
decker bus float for barcel sports this
year oh that's pretty cool yeah last
year I only had a pickup truck but this
year we got a double decker float you
got budget this year my mommy does came
in I know can't say that in front of the
Sprint that's okay yeah that's well
that's a tequila based cocktail this is
a wine a wine wine based cocktail you
know why I love podcasting with you why
because you make me feel like I talk
like at a normal Pace oh yeah you
you people have to slow down on the
podcast with an apple podcast you can
like slow it down people have to do that
to me all the time honestly I feel like
I am a professional speed talker and I
can understand people who talk really
fast I swear to God I missed half of
what you just said yeah isn't it amazing
well you know we're busy we're busy New
York girls about town and we could fill
this podcast with what another podcast
would do in three hours yeah it doesn't
feel good yeah it's all about you know
time management so you are going to join
me today for the Fast Five we're going
to talk about what's going on in the
world of Pop Culture I'm so excited and
it's Wednesday which is the day we do
our deer toasters so we have the girlies
writing in their distressed they're in
need of our help your toasters have
again they're such a mafia and they get
themselves into some pickles we have
some stories I I chose more of the
unhinged ones because I know you like to
go there yeah and I think you're gonna
you're gonna like what you hear today I
wanna say there's like at least like 67
of my fans come up to me and say I've
discovered you from the toast seriously
I love that that's why I wore this
outfit today oh yes it's very toasty in
case any um in case there's any um
casting agents out there yes I mean if
there are any cats agents out there
don't look at Joey look right at me yeah
this is my show are you upset that you
didn't get called for for the new and
improved New York Housewives because you
would have been Perfection on that show
I don't I I I am upset because I want to
be considered for everything but I don't
think I would have uh considered it yeah
okay I don't I'm excited for Jenna Lyons
on that show I mean I met uba oh
everything model everything yeah yeah
she's hot funny beautiful she's funny
too funny pretty and funny yeah I know
it was like I wanted to hate her but she
was so nice Uber she was really kind of
everything oh I love Jenna Lions yeah
well she's like a name is she a lesbian
yeah she's loved that I know she was
born with no teeth or eyelashes what
it's just Google it's a whole story she
talks about it in um interviews how did
she get teeth and eyelashes well she has
her new eyelash line she sells oh that's
smart she has an eyelash line she sells
and teeth I think she just went you know
straight to the top turkey
Chase turkey should I get a hair
transplant in Turkey
should you yeah I think I want to do it
by the way you have great hair so I
actually don't think you need it but if
you were to go get it for whatever
reason I have heard wonderful things
because they give you a free trip out
there if there's any balding toasting
men out there yeah turkey will hook you
up they give you a free flight they put
you up in luxury accommodations and they
say that the flight from Turkey back to
New York City is filled with people with
like head wraps and nose bandages their
mouths completely like [__] just the
same thing coming back from where do the
girls get the bbls now oh it's South
America yeah so they come back from
there like on their knees backwards on a
chair do you ever watch Darcy and Stacy
no who are they oh my God the TLC Queens
no you don't know Darcy Silva are they
the 600 pound life girls no they're two
sisters I think they were discovered on
like Married at First Sight or 90 Day
Fiance and they got their own spin-off
and they took a trip to Turkey on the
show and they got it all waist hip good
for them eyes it was really interesting
lucky girls lucky girls I'm trying to
figure out how to sit I know Megan
marbles told me one time you're supposed
to sit with her ankles crossed that's
the Royal Way
but I want to sit like this you look
great I look like I have a fat whale
like this no you could never Joey okay
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try different
positions sound off in the comments
below which one you like best no that's
that's how you that's creating
engagement thank you for that now before
we dive in there's kind of been a major
update in your life since we last saw
you yes you have a boyfriend I know it's
been almost a year tell me everything
what is life like with a boyfriend after
not having one for for over for over two
almost two decades right it's surprise
that's almost surprisingly like easy and
happiest thing in my life how did you
meet we met at a bar I was in a bar you
know it was um just a regular regular
old straight bar and I went up to him
and I was myself I'll say that much as
myself I just said do you want some
weird I said yeah of course my quote was
and I thought I had a couple I think I
was drinking Hennessy at the time
um I said yes
and I thank God I didn't say shody
because I almost did I said yo you got a
fat ass okay did you mean fat with an F
or fat yeah
um and you know and then we kind of like
met and we started hanging out at that
party we realized we had like a lot of
stuff in common and we got we got along
really well and just like you know it
was just easy and
it's insane like to know how easy it
could be like you know these everyone
says wait for the right person and it's
so such a [__] like textbook thing
yeah but it literally is I mean you
found yours at 19. yeah 18. what is it
called uh no um
oh my God yeah
um but you know it's just like it's when
you have to find the right person that's
right for you it's just like it's like
the easiest things you have to find the
right balance of everything so it's
about compromising I mean it sounds
[__] cliche no but it's just like
it's like the easiest thing and he's the
sweetest like kindness in my family like
um soft-spoken yes he's I'm definitely
I'm definitely the the loud star of the
show and what does he make of you like
you have this enormous personality he
loves it yeah he said that's what I
think when you first like started
hanging out he like to say these send
these a beautiful notes saying like
um I love you because you do you do this
and this is how you are and how you're
Unapologetic and you're just like out
there and just like you know the nicest
nicest thing he's the kindest man I've
ever met and it's so hard when you have
like big and it's not you have like an
authentic you don't put on no like
you're I can't turn this off no without
pills without pills it's without a
Unisom yeah it's so you and it's so
authentic and I feel the same and we're
not for everyone like we definitely
aren't a choir taste we can be a lot of
things a lot of people consider me like
too much sometimes yeah and so to find
someone who you don't have to dim your
light for is such a a blessing yeah I
know it really is I'm so happy it really
isn't it's been it's been nice you know
and I've always been terrified that all
the things I was scared of in a
relationship beforehand now it's like I
really care about his happiness and us
together so like you know you know
everyone has the inevitable thought in
their head oh God what happens if we
break up or something like that happens
my life's gonna be ruined yeah it's like
you know it's at the place where I like
we care about each other so much it's
like you know nothing will even if we do
separate I hope that never happens yeah
but like it's like you care about them
and you want you just want them to be
happy yeah we love that are you living
together
um not yet but I am moving I need your
help with that oh you're moving I've
never had a rich rich apartment before
Oh I can help you okay it's so exciting
my budge but um do you want to hear my
needs if there's any Realtors out there
I want to work with me I will not pay a
fee but I will shout you out okay on
Claudia's Instagram
um I need to have I need to have a
sectional I've never had a sectional in
my life couch okay I need a sectional
couch because the thing is me and baby
like we just lay on every time I watch a
movie I have a cute a very cute Western
couch but it's like it's definitely for
for show yeah you can't lay down and
cuddle especially I'm a large gal yeah I
understand so um
so I'm on a section so we can watch the
movies there I want to have a dining
room table I've never had a dining table
I'm a homemaker it's a luxury in New
York and you do you're such an amazing
cook I know I have to have one you have
so many weird talents like just three
you're a star and like you are a
personality yeah but you also are an
amazing Chef like like actual Chef
you're such a uh talented makeup artist
yeah you're wearing a full beat today
you look Glam thank you and what's your
third hair well no it's um yeah cooking
Beauty and comedy that's the three
things comedy yeah yeah yeah it's so
interesting I do like a table that's
more of a hobby yeah so you need a
dining room I need a dining room table
I'm nothing huge I I prefer not a cafe
table but I do I would like at least a
four or six season yeah yeah
um I need to have a king size bedroom
obviously of course outdoor space is
preferred but not like I know what I'm
gonna if I get a high-rise I'm gonna
have to have a balcony I don't want a
balcony I want to be able to like plant
[__] yeah it's not a deal breaker I'm
not gonna have any sunlight if I have
the Upper East Side because I don't have
to be in the backyard there's no sun
back there I just need Windows I don't
have a window or I don't have a
countertop in my kitchen would you leave
the burrow
no Brooklyn maybe I mean I I really if I
was if I was buying something I would go
to Brooklyn are you buying a rental I'm
renting yeah did you buy yours no oh
yeah I love renting yeah I live like a
very Carefree life you have a side home
a side has a home a what do you have a
side home a second country home no I
don't one thing about me I have
absolutely no Financial assets I don't
have a car I live like it's rich I don't
have I have like a completely untethered
life yeah Jackie's really showing us
both up she has 10 kids she has two
homes yeah well she has one home and one
kid
machine in their house no that's Shannon
oh my other red-headed friend
yeah you should meet Shannon I've met
her I think oh good who's she's been
running with she's been making the
rounds I know that she's a podcast girly
and she's been like podcasting with
everyone I've been seeing her around um
she was hanging out with my friend Alex
Bennett the other day Okay
um she hangs out with you oh yeah you
borrowed all her costumes all her
outfits at the stagecoach exactly so a
fun fact about Joey is you're a huge
country music fan yes which is so
unexpected you're just so Dynamic I know
I love country music and we're gonna
talk that's our first story a little of
the Morgan Wallen drama uh an update in
this story and I want to get your
thoughts on Morgan Wallen so should we
dive in can we come before we dive in
yeah because I have one very important
question for you sure who is turdy
I've been seeing these comments
everywhere and I was and I know I'm
assuming guessing from from The Toasters
are saying is it your skinny Alter Ego
you know I mean that's a good way of
thinking about it but it's just me it's
my nickname turdy how do you get it okay
so it all started when Emily Ratajkowski
got married is she coming to show yet no
she has her own podcast I know uh we're
just um very different I don't think we
would get along I don't I don't think
it's a match okay um so her husband's
name was Sebastian McClurg
so Jackie started calling me Sebastian
mcclurgia okay and then it was McClurg
and then it was cleared and then it was
turd and then it was 30 and then it was
turdy Lou got it and then when the
Murdoch trial was happening it was
Turtle Murda I was just there where in
South Carolina Oh I thought you meant
like at the Murdoch's house no what was
it like
um Charleston yeah it was cute it is
cute I don't think I don't think I did
the right things I hung out some good
places but I I was expecting to be more
Southern Charm like sitting on a porch
with a mint julep and like and like
eating you know tea sandwiches it wasn't
that it wasn't it was something quite
different but it was fun um but
charity okay I'm so glad we cleared that
up thank you for asking no because I was
I was seeing it I felt like I was not in
on the joke it's almost like when do you
know um you know when uh Nicole and call
Richie and Paris
you know the story no you never found
out the story the thing is like at this
point we want to know it doesn't even
matter I'm sure it would be a letdown
yeah okay yeah but
what do you think about Luanne and
Sonia's like new spin-off show that is
like a simple life type of show I'm
excited to see it bad they're coming on
um my podcast they are yes they are I
don't know I don't know much about it I
know that Luanne was saying that they
filmed it already they refilled a bunch
of it yeah because Luanne was in I just
came over solo once
um it's filmed and it's coming out soon
I'm excited for it me too I like them
changing up the format are they both
sober
I hope that Luanne is still sober and I
don't know if Sonia is yeah I need
someone I need one of them to take to
take a little bit I don't think they
will turn into the show okay
um would you ever become sober I would
you would you know I definitely would I
mean it's done that I I but I would
definitely not be like fully sober I
would need I would stop drinking but I
would need something to like take the
edge like I don't know why they even
invented a pill I only will start I
would only stop to lose weight I
wouldn't stop right for like for like
health reasons right
um but like one of the events a pill
that's exactly like not because taking
weed gum is not the same as getting
drunk so why can't they take a drunk
pill no that's a really good point like
without the calories dummies are such
like downers they're downers and they're
trying to eating so hungry I know but if
there's an alcohol pill if there's any
scientists out there yeah in the lab
right now listening to the toast invent
that pill not buy it I'll buy it too in
a second okay sorry I cut you off did
you want to get back to the five oh I
mean we do eventually like have to get
into it but we don't have to if you
don't want to no I do I also love all
these things again these all these
custom things oh you like my merch do
you sell that no we don't
we don't but we should do you want one I
would love one can I just have the iPads
no all right ready for the best time
stories that you need to know give me a
crunch
that was good very good that was better
than Ben well don't tell him I said that
today's episode is brought to you by
stamps.com with so much of our world
digitized and automated why stick to Old
School mailing and shipping if you mail
or ship often letstamps.com do the hard
part for you simply print Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes
there's no long lines and no complicated
setup required so it's basically the
post office in your office postage rates
have just increased again luckily
stamps.com has the best discounts in the
industry they have amazing Partnerships
with USPS and ups for unbeatable rates
up to 84 off plus stamps.com
automatically lets you tell
automatically tells you the cheapest and
fastest shipping options for you
stamps.com is just like a reputable
business everybody knows them they've
been around for 25 years they've been an
indispensable resource for over a
million businesses so whether you have a
side hustle an e-commerce business an
Etsy shop where you just like do a lot
of shipping in your day-to-day
stamps.com will make it so much easier
for you all you need is a computer and a
printer and they even send you a free
scale so you'll have everything you need
to get started if you need a package
pickup you can easily schedule it
through your stamps.com dashboard if
you're selling products online
stamps.com will seamlessly connect to
every major Marketplace and shopping
cart so avoid the hassle and get started
with stamps.com today sign up with our
promo code toast you'll get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there are no long-term commitments
or contracts again go to stamps.com
Click the microphone at the top of the
home page and enter code toast
t-o-a-s-t stamps.com code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
nutrifall 30 million women are impacted
by weekend or thinning hair if you're
among them you know how treacherous it
can be but do you know that you're not
alone and there is a solution out there
for you that can deliver results so this
is kind of like my cross to bear these
days I've been experiencing hair
shedding and it was really scary at
first because I would just brush my hair
or take a shower and I would just
literally have clumps falling out and I
took to Instagram to ask people what
they're doing for for their hair issues
and everyone in my personal life on
social media recommended neutralfall
it's super common but it's just not
openly talked about especially amongst
women going through it can feel really
like lonely and frustrating but
neutralfall is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement it's clinically shown to
improve your hair growth thickness and
visible scalp coverage they support
healthy hair growth from within by
targeting the five root causes of
thinning which can be stress hormones
environment nutrition and metabolism and
they do that through whole body Health
they have three unique formulas at
nutrifault to support women throughout
all stages of life I know a lot of
people experience hair change it
happened to Jackie when she was pregnant
and then postpartum can cause a lot of
hair loss so they're supporting you
through all stages of life whether
that's postpartum or menopause each
formula is physician formulated using
natural drug-free medical grade
ingredients in consistently effective
dosages so you would get the most
reliable results you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support the toast by
going to neutrophone.com enter the promo
code the toast and you'll save ten
dollars off your first month's
subscription the offer is only available
to us customers and it's only for a
limited time time you'll also get free
shipping on every order so that's ten
dollars off when you go to nutrifall.com
which is spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code the toast
all right our first story is a little
country music news let me get your take
on this whole crisis from start to
finish I remember this but Morgan Wallen
is officially cleared to sing after
canceling six weeks of tour dates and
being on vocal rest the country singer
announced that he was given the okay to
talk and sing after being on a week's
long vocal right you can even talk no
does she have a notepad she was passing
around going like must have been he said
the doc cleared me to talk and saying
we're back so I guess that means he's
going to be rescheduling all the shows
now there was a lot of Doubt
when it came out that he was going to be
put on vocal rest because there's been
rumors about him you know struggling
with alcohol and like you know people
said I saw him at a bar the day before
the show what was your take on the whole
thing my take on the whole thing is it's
devastating anytime you have to let the
fans sound like that or do something big
like that so there has to be something
very substantial for him to have to do
that and I don't think it's being like
that because he canceled the whole show
because I mean he answered a whole tour
yeah so if he was if he was really drunk
just [__] up he would have picked up
like a couple days after because that's
just a lot of money and then even
Insurance all that [__] goes there he's
he's out on a lot of money True by doing
that so he if he was just drunk he would
have picked up sooner than right they
want to put him on some Adderall you
know what I mean yeah I mean I'm sure he
was like messy you know when you're on
tour he's a rock star so right that's
kind of what happens
um I don't think maybe that night it was
but I think that it had to have been
like a a real progression of things of
his health maybe maybe um alluded to not
maybe due to him being drunk yeah all
the time right you can get sick when
you're drinking so much yeah so I think
it could have been caused by that but I
don't think that's why I don't think he
like got [__] up and then had to
cancel the thing did you have tickets
for the New York show I did not have
tickets thank God I mean I would be
upset if we um lost them that was like
planning on going but one thing about me
I'm not gonna buy tickets till the day
before like I'm sorry I always do that
one I'm so lazy but how do you get the
good tickets well
the cool thing about being a touring
artist is you have access to lots of
tickets you know that's kind of one of
one of my perks I do as well I'm sure
you have a lot through the game time app
to the game time use code toast yeah you
use code stool for twenty dollars no use
kotos
and by the way that [__] is good like
it's a bad no serious game time is the
best yeah code toast [__] okay
um have you are you gonna go to the
era's tour what are your thoughts on
Taylor Swift okay I talked about this
gesture I am so excited for the people
for the for the swifties were they
called swifties they're strictly I'm so
excited for them because they are so
they're passionate about an artist and
she is giving it to you [__] full on
I'm not that I'm not that gal that's
fine I I appreciate her I think she's
stunning I think she's brilliant she's
you know a great music artist what did
Aretha Franklin say pretty gal yes
beautiful gowns that was me yeah Aretha
was wrong for that yeah pretty good um I
so I get I get the vibe with it um all
her songs are Bob so I'm sure I've heard
a bunch of her songs you would know a
lot I was I was wanted to go for the pop
culture things it became such a
phenomenon taken over the world the
globe yes every time she has a show
there's like 10 stories on page six yeah
so I'm so excited and everything's um I
want to see her dive into the stage
there's like so many things but it's a
lot of money to spend if you're not like
that's what I said so if somebody
offered you a ticket you would go yeah I
wasn't offered a free ticket I didn't go
why
um because I was in South Carolina got
it yeah and you feel good about that
decision uh yeah even though you just
said you didn't even like really like it
that much yeah I mean it was it was a
shitty time all around but I didn't I
didn't um I didn't miss out too much but
I'm excited that she's doing well I
think I think she's giving the fans like
everything I think the ticket prices are
a little crazy I mean but get that bag
mama no I mean you would I didn't I did
not get free She's Gotta Get She's Gotta
make money back because she got did she
get robbed of all her songs from uh
scooter Browns right Scooter Brown so
she is on a mission to she's also
probably by the end of the year gonna
become a billionaire oh her net worth is
not one yet no her net worth is slinging
those lip gloss it makes more than she
does yeah what even though I think on
the Forbes list that just came out Kylie
was actually lower than Taylor Taylor
punctuates people don't realize about
rich people like us our Capital will
fluctuate our Capital will fluctuate and
it's more about like your assets like
Kylie's business was worth a billion
dollars not Kylie herself you know um so
Taylor was recently uh ranked at 750
million dollars and her tour will
generate over a billion dollars and she
will become a billionaire by the time is
she with a record label now she has her
own label no she's with a record label
but she when she was you know brought to
the market to meet all the different
record labels she was only interested in
meeting with record labels that would
help release her music but she owned the
Masters to them yeah because now there's
ever I see a lot of switches going on
um on Tick Tock they mistakenly listened
to the old version right and then they
thought they were gonna you know she was
gonna find out right like she was like
they were gonna get shot side note uh
toasters do you remember do you see the
video of um Tina Knowles getting pulled
out of the crowd when she got lost oh my
God I was dying I brought this up on the
toes
came out
thank you get in the pit and then all
the fans literally hoisted her up and
brought her back to security what was
that I think I think you she I think
when I looked when I looked at it was
ground flourish I could assume that she
was like in that area she might have
stumbled out of a back room so I saw the
stage figured she could just be able to
walk through and there would be an
opening but there wasn't an opening
there oh my God I'm so glad you brought
that up are you gonna see Beyonce I
would love to see Beyonce yes so I have
like the same thing if somebody offered
me a ticket I would totally go but I'm
not gonna buy a ticket yeah yeah but
I've been seeing some content and it
looks really fun it looks really there's
a door she comes down on a horse there's
Vogue Queens there's a whole like
there's Blue Ivy Blue Ivy yeah she she
performs as well the box braids I would
love your thoughts on nepo babies
um I'm well it's it's I'm annoyed that
I'm not a nipple baby same yeah so I'm
just so pissed about it I mean I'm
I think it's great I'm not mad in the
slightest I'm not mad I mean you know if
God you know brought you know approaches
in the world and that's your things what
you do with it I think is different
thing I mean you could be talented if
you're not talented then it's just like
anything else but I think that you know
it's like I said Beyonce has the same 24
hours in a day than we as we do you know
what I mean no that's what Jackie and I
always say like the cream Rises like you
can get the opportunity but if you stink
you stink yeah can make people like it
can't make you talented Money Can't Make
You likeable yeah and many Captain you
know if you say you want to be a singer
look at uh Kristen Stewart she when she
wants to sing or whatever she's a
reality star she came from a beautiful
family and had a reality and where is
she now it's like you know she wasn't
good it wasn't for her Kristen Stewart
as in Twilight Kristen Stewart no
Kristen Stewart like Rod Stewart's
daughter oh Kimberly Kimberly Stewart
sorry I'm like Kimber I'm like Kristen
Stewart tried to sing and be on reality
TV
that was just one thing that came to my
mind by the way that's an amazing
example of like nepotism being only a
springboard yeah and when you think of
Kimberly Stewart's most iconic pop
culture moments what do you think of oh
the motorcycle of course oh my God I'm
so glad you said yes of course when she
in Paris tried to ride a motorcycle on
the red carpet and like almost killed 10
people most iconic those events were so
cringy and sugar like oh we're doing a
pop-up for yogurt squirts they would
show up to like any any event and they
were getting paid Aid yeah no you're
right Kimberly Stewart is the greatest
example of nepotism really not it's it's
a two-way street yeah you make what's
best I mean
um you know the the Richie that that
girl Sophia she's the it girl now she's
now she knows she she's got it she's
talented at influencing and you know
having style she's a style icon she is
she really is and Jackie and I were
saying last week because she go to her
wedding I did not she was we checking I
was saying last week how she's really
influencing a younger generation to
dress so like not modest but classy and
yeah whereas I feel like for a while
like thought he was the vibe and never
had their tits and asses out and now
everyone's wearing like pea coats
I know she definitely showers everybody
who did you go to her wedding who that
octopus lover I had dinner with him two
nights ago I'm upset I heard him okay
listen I was walking down the hall I
hear a gay person coming through the
walls and I'm going like this at the
office I'm at Barstool and I'm like
there's another there's a gay in the
office I can hear her your radar yeah
she uh he was in um chicks in the office
so I go in there I say did you have a
gay person in your room because yeah I
freaked out he's not going to be
available for my um podcast to come on
when he's here in New York but oh he's
not coming in yours he's not coming on
the toast big toaster but I think he
wants to prepare for his big his name is
Jake Shane he's so talented I'm so glad
you know who he is yesterday Taylor
strecker was like what are you talking
about he's the funniest [__] person
when he did number two one pencil number
two he goes hi
hi he's so funny he's really when I met
him in person he's so down to earth good
you're gonna like love him oh good and
he's here for the weekend I'm gonna hang
out with him this weekend if you want to
come okay good are you around this
weekend yeah yeah we need to hang we
haven't hang out I know we have like a
year where we went out hard like we were
nuts I know we need to do that again
remember Finn fell in his head Ben fell
on his head my friend fell in his head
nowhere it was that like some part I
think it was like one of those down you
always see my little bars that are
downstairs yeah lots of stairs involved
I know one thing about me it's like if
the bathroom's downstairs I'm not going
I'll shut my pants just like you in the
Uber
okay ready for a little bit more pop
culture yes okay so tonight is the
season finale third episode for the
reunion of vanderpumper how many is this
the last one this is the last one and
everyone has been saying that there's
this big reveal at the end of the
episode reveal a reveal yourself
that was good and nobody knows what it
is people are speculating that Raquel is
pregnant and James Kennedy has taken to
Instagram to tease this big thing being
like this is not a drill so he made a
video he said guys if you think it's
been a wild ride thus far strap your
bloody seat belts the madness begins
tomorrow this is not a drill get ready
just watched he was the official
official uh um wrestler
of the tea so we still don't know what
it is and the fact that they're blowing
it up so much I feel like we can really
only be let down yeah because now people
are saying like
what if Raquel is in fact pregnant
because she like has not been that would
truly Raquel is the one that got the one
that the the mistress the mistress and
if she's pregnant that would truly be
the craziest thing of all time
he's still going out performing I guess
he's a he's a he's a cover band oh Tom
yeah oh God why is everyone call him
worm with a mustache because at part one
of the reunion James was getting so mad
at him he was like shut up you're a
[__] worm with a mustache and that
really took off oh he got it it's
trending it's trending
um I think that
first of all it's like I said I don't
know I don't know why it got so big and
I'm saying Cheney's never right I guess
he got so big because it was like it was
she was the best friend and she was like
a secret thing but yeah I don't know why
this there's something wrong with that
actual actual meat of the story is a
little bit out of like blown out of
proportion for what actually happened
like no if you've been watching and like
you know these people it's really the
craziest thing because they're best
friends like sure so these two lit
chicks where I hang out all day and like
all season people and that's [__] up
people were coming for Raquel saying
like she's not to be trusted with your
man and Ariana was like she's my best
friend you guys like she's rode so hard
for this girl we like Ariana we love
Ariana she's the hero she wasn't she
didn't she do that's Chris and Jody
though in the beginning right so that's
what kind of the underlying hypocrisy of
this whole group it wasn't really cheap
it wasn't an affair though it was like
you know like they weren't the timelines
were like a little blurry but this is
the full-on Kristen Dodie's not mad so
like I guess we can be yeah do you know
any of the Vanderpump peeps
um I forgot probably I'm for sure I met
I'm sure I've hung out with a bunch of
them right before
um but I don't have anyone's phone
number no you don't have like personal
relationships like you don't have any
tea you could tell me no not on those
girls no well Jax and Brittany are
coming on the channel he's nice he's
lovely I saw his name on your mind um
for the yes on the toast lineup he's
coming on Friday him and Brittany are
recording with me tomorrow so they're
married and doing well married doing
well I'm glad that happened he was a bet
he was the bad one he was the original
Tom villain villain sleeping around and
towards his end of you know his time on
the show like tenure his 10 years was
the end of his tenure he was really just
like on this mission to show everyone
that Tom Sandoval was a bad guy and now
he's been Vindicated has Tom Tom bar
opened up since yes since yes has it
been vandalized yes it has really it has
my God people writing team Ariana and
lipstick it's been vandalized oh my God
this is like crazy it's like serious
Joey I said I should have went to um La
Pride now that I'm thinking about it
yeah because there's definitely gonna be
something going down if they're filming
especially and they always film during
Pride yeah
my God I just feel bad for all parties
involved not for Tom because Tom did
that willingly but both those girls and
I think it's always the boy's fault I
agree don't you think have you ever
cheated no I would never have you ever
been cheated on yes that's why I haven't
dated for years you cheated on me who
Tim Tim I hate him from 2012. was it an
affair was it like a one-time I don't
know it was like you know yeah it was a
couple of times that they hung out how
did you find out he told me oh wow he's
drinking at Blue Powerade at the time
and have you ever been able to stop
right since no I can't even look at it
and I was at a while but I remember that
day very rivly were on the beach and I
was drinking skinny girl Margaritas out
of the bottle and it's kind of like
[__] up of him to do it like out of a
Wawa because then that kind of puts like
a negative yeah stamp on Wawa when it's
such a fabulous establishment yeah well
our Pub Subs voila more than pops up
yeah so I actually recently had a pub
sub for the first time same I didn't
think it was all that it was cracked up
to be Wawa's much better yeah I like and
the Wawa mac and cheese
have you had the Panera mac and cheese I
have actually I actually don't think
it's good no what about Chick-fil-A mac
and cheese I actually have never had it
oh it's fire the best the best Mac and
Cheese fast food say on the count of
three one I don't know okay take a
minute to think about it because it's so
I haven't mentioned it yet no
fast food mac and cheese yeah
who else has mac and cheese
tell me about Boston Market Boston
Market I was gonna say Boston Market and
KFC have really really similar um I like
KFC's coleslaw no KFC's mac and cheese
like seriously there will come a time in
my life where like I don't care about
what I look like anymore and I will eat
it for breakfast lunch and dinner for
the rest of my life I think I'm gonna
get it this week no it's on Postmates
but Boston Market or KFC they're just as
good we're gonna be at Boston Market
around nowadays in the city ah there
might be one in Penn Station Street yeah
Penn Station's disgusting in some like
forlorn district there is the Monahan
train station the one just say
the Moynihan train Hall what is that
it's the fancy Penn Station they built
across the street no and I took the
Amtrak for the first time they have a
first class Lounge just like Delta Sky
Lounge you're like the Points Guy why
he was optioned to come over my house on
my podcast oh he should come on should
come up yeah I need to find out points
you do need to get your points game but
I have that I have the silver the
platinum card but I also need to have
that you need the gold why four points
on dining oh and that's all I spend my
money on so the MX goals I'll get that
one MX gold is like Loki a better
cheaper card that's what I've learned
from Brian oh and if you go to the
pointsky.com toast they have the best
cards for toasters every time I get on
the plane and I see points guys stick
around the side of the boat I say to the
lady that's my friend I know by the way
same I touch it I'm like you guys I
touch it I know this guy I feel so proud
of him
you need to get your points game on
fleek like you I travel pretty much for
free I know I gotta do that yeah and
it's actually like I thought it was a
thing that like rich people don't do but
now that you're rich like yeah rich
people don't spend money on anything
yeah and that's the points that I gotta
try to I gotta try to get it Brian will
give you like a full
course adventurous Sapphire or a blue
sapphire is good too the blue card no
not blue sapphire Reserve that's when I
should go yeah that's a good one but
honestly the AmEx gold is the best card
oh I have to go get one yeah go apply do
you have good credit
um it's you know I didn't have good
credits I never really had I didn't I
thought I had bad credit I never had no
credit yeah for everything me too and
that's when I met Brian and he was like
offended well now my apartment now my
apartment's coming up I might my thing
lost 22 points this month your credit
went down because I was spending too
much money well no one tells you this
yeah you're like not supposed to use all
of your credit limit I was I was maxing
that not Max I was I'm not maxing I was
spending all a lot of money and then
paying it off like twice a month right
right right like I was like letting it
go into delinquent well now that you're
moving there is a credit card it's
called built that you can earn points on
rent
today's episode is also brought to you
by Thomas
introducing the bed by thuma it's
handcrafted from eco-friendly high
quality upcycled wood the bed has a
modern minimalist design that helps
Elevate any space it's super supportive
for your mattress it's breathable and
it's made to naturally minimize noise
and create space the bed is put together
by using the Timeless technique of
Japanese joinery each piece locks into
place which means that no tools or
excess Hardware are required for
assembly with clean lines subtle curves
and lifestyle enhancing details the bed
is simple sophistication for the bedroom
Jackie got a Therma bed for what we're
calling snitch's room at her house in
Florida and let me tell you it really
was that easy no screwdrivers none of
that business comes in three boxes
they're really easy to maneuver the bed
sets up really easily and I swear it
doesn't take more than five minutes the
perfect platform bed also just got
better because you can now customize the
bed by choosing between the original
pillow board or a new solid wood
headboard if that's more of your
aesthetic the headboard attaches Direct
to the bed and there again no tools
required it's also made for how you live
it's backed with a lifetime warranty it
ships right to your door and it takes
about five minutes to assemble with like
I said no tools required along with the
bed Suma offers other bedroom Essentials
to elevate bedtime the mattress the
nightstand the side table they're all
the perfect compliments to the bed and
they also have financing options
available on their website create that
feeling of checking into your favorite
boutique hotel suite but at home with
the bed by thuma and now go to thuma.co
toast to receive a 25 credit towards
your purchase of the bed plus free
shipping in the continental US go to
thuma.co toast t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for a 25 credit today's episode is
also brought to you by better sleep we
all want to feel ready to conquer the
day when we wake up but when you've got
a lot on your mind it's really tough to
get the rest that you need with the
better sleep app you can personalize a
sleep experience that calms your racing
thoughts and boosts concentration in
fact Business Insider says that better
sleep is one of the most positively
reviewed apps in the history of the
Apple Store let me tell you how this
used to be something I would kind of
roll my eyes out I'm like if I can't
sleep nothing's going to help but let me
tell you how this works and how at peace
I feel and what a difference it's made
and how I wake up and how I feel in the
morning so they have over 200 soothing
sounds and a range of Smart features to
help you sleep faster deeper and for
longer you can explore audio tracks from
categories like ASMR which I love brain
waves meditations stories you can use a
pre-made soundscape mix or combine your
favorite sounds color noises Melodies
Etc it's an award-winning app that works
it's the most positively reviewed apps
in the Apple App Store it's named was
named Apple's app of the day over 65
times it's backed by Sleep Experts and
science so high quality rest is vital to
mental well being and physical health so
better sleep collaborated with
world-renowned sleep specialists in
Oxford University Professor Dr Russell
Foster to help you achieve your best
sleep when you sleep better you feel
better improve your quality of life in
as little as one week download better
sleep from the app store or Google play
that's better sleep on the app store or
Google play better sleep is of course
b-e-t-t-e-r-s-l-e-e-p if you're having
trouble sleeping staying asleep Sleeping
deep take control
I need to get all this because I'm my my
least I'm leaving on October and I need
to have I need to go up at least 25
years moving up in the world Joey and
you your finances have to reflect that I
know we'll get you there okay okay next
story Our Queen Kim Cattrall is talking
about aging and she's not giving us 66.
she is she's in her 60s she won't say
but she's in her 60s 66. yeah
um and she's not feeding us that like
sort of thing everyone is like I'm
embracing aging she says no I am
battling Aging in every way I can and
that includes here Botox she you know
she had experienced a major loss yeah so
she had a candid conversation about
aging the 66 year old actress revealed
that she's fighting growing older in an
interview with the Sunday Times she said
that in my 60s now I am battling Aging
in every way I can there's so many other
Alternatives now treatments that can
simulate your own body to fight aging
there are fillers Botox there are so
many different things that you can
investigate and try and see if it's for
you if you have the money and more
importantly the right surgeon it can't
be emphasized enough you want to look
like you it's not just a vanity thing I
play a certain kind of woman who looks a
certain kind of way and professionally
I'm looking after myself I so appreciate
her like candid and like directly what
was she what was it what was this clap
back about some people saying you're
getting too much surgery no I think like
they were just having an open
conversation about aging and I think
most women are like I'm being honest
about and she's like no [__] I'm
supposed to be playing fabulous women
yeah and fabulous women get BOTOX well
you remember from many moons Samantha
Jones was um taking hormones things and
eating hummus yes
she couldn't get her yams yes so Paula
Abdul had to get was it her no oh yeah
no it was her like servant who was
called his name was Abdul but they he
introduced himself I'm Abdul like Paula
yes I remember another thing from there
in Mexico my favorite line chair was
said when he's camera bringing like
bringing fresh fruit over she goes oh
thank you Paolo literally I remember
that and Charlotte's just eating the
pudding yeah and then Charlotte shoots
her
pantsied her pants I know
um oh yeah I I'm all about that I have a
fabulous Med Spa that I'm I I go to
you're not embracing the Aging you're
not going no me neither why would I do
that no how old are you if you don't
mind me asking 44. you look great thank
you I would have thought you're like 36.
well thank you I go I get um you know
Botox the fillers the jaw fillers do you
have a gray hair problem we were talking
about yesterday yeah my whole beard is
painted on right now really I moved the
wrong way I'll get it on your bouncil
chair what do you is that what it's
called it's actually boucle but we call
it clay I could never pronounce it
neither can we that's why we call it
buccal
um what do you use on your beard to Just
For Men oh like the uh I Disappeared die
most of the time but then jesterman also
has this um this beard mascara but but I
that's not my favorite product my
favorite product is a beard I love that
one but for me a lot of women use that
on their eyebrows I use this this is a
trade secret
um everyone their mother uses the um the
root sprays yeah so I use Rita Hayes on
exactly Rita is on root spray I use um
as to fill my beard in if you have any
bald spots or thinning hair yeah if you
have a snatched ponytail and your roots
are showing yeah yeah on the Rita Haze
on spray and you spray it in your roots
and it colors it in or if you have like
a lot of people um struggle with like
thin scalp covers yes that's what I got
that's what I use but on my beard I use
that or sometimes a little dark brown
mascara
um from your ladies purse on a pinch you
can take all your gray whiskers and push
them away I quite literally would have
never guessed that that wasn't just your
beard yeah it looks you did a great job
well thank you and so I'm all here for
this I'm not I commend women who embrace
the Aging but I also think like we can
applaud women who don't want it yeah
like look speaking of uh sex in the
cities SJP perfect opportunity I'm sure
she's Nixon Plex a little here and there
but she's embracing age she's growing
her Grays out yep sure faces and I don't
think she really does do Botox doesn't
seem like she does no but she looks
pretty good she must be doing something
something yeah maybe she's doing those
um those facial exercises I just love
that like Kim Cattrall is talking about
it you know it's like great now how do
you think about her coming back just for
well I wonder how much money Darren
Starr gave her I know it was a little
bit of a tease when they announced it
she's not filming with anyone it's a
phone call and she's by herself and she
went to set and didn't even have to see
anyone yeah yeah so it's just like
copying character it's not bad her
character's not bad but I guess it
leaves it opens the door
yeah I would like to hear back I don't
know how she'd play I'm not I'm not the
biggest fan of just like that me neither
but I can't stop watching it I do like I
do like it I like um I like that Aiden's
coming back this season okay rank the
four main OG Sex in the City characters
from best to worst
um well the worst ones Carrie agreed
she's a nightmare so for Carrie if you
ever met her in person the nightmare
like Carrie or SCP
is lovely okay and then um
then I see so much myself in Charlotte
and
um I'm over I'm like a Charlotte and
Samantha myself so I would say she's the
worst to best the best one Samantha okay
but then I would say
Charlotte I guess okay and then so then
Miranda and then Miranda the Tiffany I
would go definitely carry last yeah and
then I think I would do Charlotte I'm
not I don't feel connected to Charlotte
she's kind of annoying yeah and it would
be a tie for first between Miranda
Miranda and Samantha Samantha is
everything like when you re-watch a show
you realize like she's the star yeah of
course all the best one-liners are from
here the best advice yes that's the best
fashion right like Carrie was the
fashion girly the maxinista and really
Samantha was out here pulling looks yeah
I'm so glad we were right on Carrie made
the absolute worst that's like a lesson
you learn I feel like when you watch a
show as a young person you don't realize
it but she is no and then you actually
watch a show as like an adult with you
know your own life and your own friends
and you realize like if this [__] was
in my life I would cut her out in 10
[__] horrible friends toxic toxic
horrible friends self-centered I mean
the right everything comes back to
Carrie but the episode where she like
her apartment's going Co-op yes and why
didn't you offer me the money right get
the [__] out of here and it's like
you're literally a woman of a certain
age you have a career you're kind of a
celebrity and you've chosen to spend all
your money on kitten heels why is that
Charlotte's problem why is that
Charlotte's problem yeah yeah oh my God
that bothered me so much I know all
right speaking of people that bother me
um Mark Consuelos is divulging and
whether or not he or Kelly Ripa is the
hornier one in the marriage yeah how no
I've been speaking of Arkansas what I've
heard of him as of late is he took over
for Ryan Seacrest or Mike yeah both both
of them so he's a new co-host so now
it's like you know the couple's host the
nepo husband it's and it's not
supposedly not supposedly not going well
for the first season yeah I've heard
it's just like you know I feel like it
takes time to get used to a co-host not
everyone could be a joke and he never
really did he never really did hosting
no you know remember from All My
Children and you know the Riverdale yeah
the actor the sexy actor
um so I think it's gonna take a while to
get his footing in there but now he's in
the news so much because everything he
says is getting picked up and so Mark
Consuelos went on watch weapons live and
he obviously started talking about him
and Kelly's sex life because what else
do these two people talk about and they
were doing the agree disagree thing
where Andy gives you a paddle and you
either he says a statement he says a
statement and you basically agree or
disagree and the statement was my
partner my partner is hornier than me
and Mark Consuelos did disagree and he
said he was the hornier one
I think that the woman was a horny one
because as you know as we know from from
biology class women find their um their
hornies in their 40s and men are like in
their teens they're like no you're right
so I would think that would be her being
the hornier one but I guess you know men
men are always horny oh she's pretty
have you had Andy comment on the podcast
no he he didn't come on but I was on his
I was a guest bartender oh how was that
I've done that last year I did it and
was it a dream come true no he didn't
let me get a word in edgewise until the
after show no okay until the after show
same same same I went when I was in
college it was like my biggest dream and
it was like amazing to be there and I
was like so excited I had like all these
jokes prepared all these one-liners and
you guys are gonna do a monologue he did
throw me he's like you're a big Bravo
fan I was like this is my time and I was
like yeah and I had like all these
things I wanted to say and he was like
that's great Claudia thanks for joining
us it is so exciting but you get half a
second yeah yeah I just know that one
day we'll be on the couch a hundred
percent yeah yeah
um okay was that all we had to say about
Mark Consuelos like genuinely like not
to be rude who cares uh our fifth and
final story before we dive into some
deer toasters which I'm just dying to
hear from you let's see what they have
it's a little you know business news
Starbucks is bringing their line of
aval aisle olive oil coffee oh to more
cities now is that a version of like the
keto coffee that had butter in it I have
no idea they're going full steam ahead
with their controversial line of olive
oil infused coffee drinks expanding one
of the biggest new product launches in
years to many more States and many more
cities so it's called olito that's what
the drinks are called o-l-e no that
reminds me of what PTSD what oh Lester
trips Elena what is that oh this is
you're too young for this
fat free chips it was fat free oil but
it says on the package will cause anal
leakage to people's there's oil like
leaking out people's [__] so I
actually went to a fat camp I know Tony
sparber's yes yes yes and during uh the
weekdays on the afternoon snack
sometimes it was a Fudgesicle that was
like a great day remember yeah but they
were blue bunny brand and if you
everyone only got one but I wasn't when
I was much younger I wasn't there you
would shank someone behind the shed to
get a second no I actually I was allowed
to get seconds because I wasn't fat like
I was on the maintenance program I was
there to support one of my sisters
if you read my book you know who I'm
talking about and they gave you this
bracelet for the summer that's just like
I'm here to happen I said I'm not fat
pretty much it's neon it's like it's so
bright and it's like the coveted
bracelet because you you could sell them
on the black market but you ain't years
prior yes and I always so she was she
was an alumni no right what's it called
alumni your sister had Legacy yes yes so
I could basically eat whatever I wanted
and I had a couple fudgicles that day
and I didn't realize on the package said
you know making may cause anal leakage
and that was actually the first time I
sharted were you wearing white shorts I
was wearing yellow because it was color
war and I actually remember what caused
me to shirt I had a few obstacles that
day I was like probably eight years old
and I I was on the gold team so I was
wearing all gold and it was the night
that color were ended and they they
announced like the winner is
gold and I jumped up I was so excited
and I ran to Olivia uh and Jackie's bunk
because it was so close to where we were
and I had charted well I can imagine the
excitement color War I was one of those
kids did you ever go to Camp no I tried
to go to Tony spiders my parents
wouldn't pay for this was three thousand
dollars by the way I was just having
this conversation with someone about how
like most I said Sherry Glazer went oh I
don't know her yeah most of my like gay
male friends didn't go to Camp because I
imagine it would have been like a
traumatizing experience yeah like a
closeted kid in a bunk of all boys
um but I feel like you so missed out on
the the experience of it like if you
could have been in the girl's buns like
you would they would have loved you oh I
know exactly what happened and so many
of my like most fond memories and crazy
stories come from Camp well all my my
friend Marty um he's a producer over at
um out and about he he's Jewish and all
your Jewish kids go to Camp here and
that's where he got that's where
everyone has their first kiss that's
where he gets finger banging first time
100 it's like no Jewish camp and it
sounds worse than it is no it was it was
you know but it's and that's where I had
my first chart yeah
congratulations thank you thanks for
like making this a safe space that I
could share that with you absolutely
um you kind of opened the door with the
[__] in the Uber well yeah I'm very
I'm very transparent about it you're so
honest I have to be so olive oil coffee
you told me you've had one I've had
olive oil cocktails and coffee cocktails
I've had does that mean they actually
put olive oil in it's actually delicious
really so they do olive oil make you
shoot your pants no um I don't think
you're drinking olive oil I think it's
like you're just like my uh cocktail I
had it just has a few drops of it it's a
few so I think it's just more of like a
way of like instead of adding a creamer
take like instead of adding um milk to
take the um to take the uh the
bitterness I think this is just rounding
the flavors so it says that each of the
Starbucks drinks are going to be
prepared with a spoonful of olive oil it
adds 120 calories according to Starbucks
and there's also a cold brew with an
olive oil infused cold foam it's called
Golden foam
uh I just feel like coffee is fine yeah
we don't need to be innovating I don't
know what are you putting fat in the
coffee anyway I'm drinking black coffee
right now do not do milk no why not
um I just cause the calories oh okay
even even the almond milk are like oat
milk it doesn't make it I like I don't
mind the taste of it so I don't have it
but I do like you know I've been doing
matcha a lot lately oh wow you're really
toxic I love matcha you do yeah but not
the um I don't do the lattes like it's
too milky for me so I do with water
um I love matcha full if you had it no
I've never heard about it oh yeah you
you I don't eat anything would you ever
find your Starbucks drink when you're
there I did actually I really like the
Starbucks drinks at the grocery store
like the jugs of iced coffee with a
little coffee mate hazelnut sugar-free I
I actually don't like anything like from
Starbucks right so I save myself a lot
of money I mean I just think I don't
think there's a need for calories I'd
rather like do I save my calories for
other things that makes a lot like I'm
showing that makes a lot of sense yes
you know it's about it's about balancing
you know in life so I'd rather eat like
zero points foods those are like that's
Weight Watchers yeah I know I'd rather
eat salads and like grilled chicken and
like nothing all day and then just get
tanked on like two bottles of wine yeah
yeah that's it and then put yourself
down with a sleeping pill so you don't
pig out so you don't pig out and look at
your Diner yeah 100 well Joey those are
the Fast Five and I couldn't have done
them without you no this is so much fun
but what's so exciting is that today's
Wednesday our weekly advice segment
called deer toasters where you can write
in uh to Deer toasters gmail.com and we
will read your prompt on gmail.com
gmail.com gmail.com and it's totally
Anonymous and we have some [__] Wild
Ones today because of course we do it's
Joey
today's episode is brought to you by the
farmer's dog when you look at bags of
dog food you see pictures of bright
carrots and juicy steaks but when you
open the bag all you get are burnt
smelly pellets well dog food needs some
fresh thinking and that's where the
farmer's dog comes in it's real food
you're feeding your dog the farmer's dog
it's real fresh healthy food whole meat
and vegetables and it's gently cooked in
human grade kitchens to preserve their
nutritional value
Theo had a lot of issues with his food
he went through this phase where he
couldn't keep food down and now that we
have switched to the farmer's dog it's
real fresh healthy it's like stored in
the fridge in the freezer it's legit
there's so many benefits he's keeping
his food down way better his breath oh
my God his breath used to be so bad his
breath is so much better his coat is
shiny he has lots of energy and he just
doesn't have those stomach problems that
he had for many many years
the meals arrive in pre-portioned ready
to serve packs it's conveniently
delivered on your schedule dog people
all across the country have ordered
millions of meals from the farmer's dog
it's never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food if you want
to get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy dog food do so at the
farmersdog.com toast plus you get free
shipping so just what you have to do is
go to thefarmersdog.com toast toast and
you will get 50 off your first box plus
free shipping invest in the health of
your stress bro like it will pay off in
Spades they will feel better they will
look better and you will feel better
just knowing that you're being an
amazing mom so that's the farmersdog.com
toast
hello Queens I have an issue my husband
is obsessed with his penis
but this is next level the infatuation
has gotten so serious that I'm truly
concerned about about it and wondering
if it might be more common and it's just
taboo to talk about here are some
examples he's upset at his parents for
circumcising him he says it takes away
30 of his sensation and it is abuse how
do you get the Third how to get the
percentage out so he uses a device to
regrow his foreskin he wears this odd
device for multiple hours a day to
stretch it out and he wakes up early to
stretch his penis out for an hour
straight he sends me pictures of his
foreskin growth at least three times a
week and talks about it non-stop he
measures and keeps track and he wants to
talk about it daily and I'm quite
frankly exhausted from it I want to be
supportive and loving but it's getting
so excessive that I almost want to ask
if he needs to see a therapist I think
his penis is perfect the way that it is
I also wish he'd use the hours
stretching his [__] to do things that
actually need to get done around the
house yes would you pretend it's fine
and just continue being supportive or
push him to find the underlying reason
for why he seems to be so in saturated
with his [__] thank you girlies a
toaster who is tuckered out
um it's not a great question and this
isn't like a thing that like nobody's
talking about but it's very common no
this is it's terrible a lot of men have
that kind of like missing out thing I
wish I had I know not I wouldn't want a
full foreskin but you know it's it is
like are you circumcised yeah but you
get like it's I think you get more dick
if it's if it is uncircumcised you
definitely get more length it's uh not
as sanitary I believe yeah no I'm fine
with it being whatever yeah but there's
definitely something underlying there
that's not normal right right to like
you know I actually uh met someone who
had a penis implant
for girth or length all the above
um actually were they gay of course of
course because I know straight man's
going through all that and when I tell
you it was all this person talked about
and it was like kind of insufferable
it was just like every conversation was
about the penis did he show everyone
yes did it look real
yes oh do you have a picture of it I
don't I don't but maybe I can get one
for you I'll ask if you're interested in
the procedure I believe he flew to
Turkey as well you can get everything
done there I would definitely find you
know it's fine I was I wouldn't shame
him or shame him for it so either figure
out what it is or my more importantly
for me it's him not getting things done
around the house when he's not
acceptable shut your dick all you want
but take out the [__] garbage yeah
I'm pretty sure you can take your dick
out take your trash out while your dick
is being stretched yes
early to put the device on but why don't
you wake up early and do the dishes yeah
and if you want why don't you tell your
husband to send me the pics instead yes
and then you don't have to worry about
seeing them and then he can be gone on
this day but yeah chores before you're
foreskin yeah tours before Horrors but I
hear you sister it can be annoying that
no and that's what triggers me like when
someone's like it's fine jewelry
contributing yeah that's where I draw
the line yeah I need you I need you to
pick this [__] up but I also need you to
know this is like definitely not normal
like this is not a thing we're all
suffering in Silence with yeah it's
definitely a unique issue and there's
probably an underlying issue and there
he might might not hurt yeah I think
there's some tremendations.com and use
code toast yeah or no
they get us all done no but I do love
better help I use it myself
to toast all right ready
ready for our next image yeah hey
girlies I'm currently going through a
divorce it'll be final in three weeks my
husband's family is very close and
tight-knit we were always together for
everything well I get a DM today in
vanish mode from his first cousin who we
did everything with like every family
event and he was asking me out to dinner
he then said it would be fun as long as
nobody knew I obviously turned it down
but do I mention it to my soon-to-be
ex-husband I don't want to cause any
drama in the family I'm about to be
divorced from them but I feel like I
would also like to know if this was
happening behind my back what should I
do mention it to my soon-to-be
ex-husband or let it go I would let it
go me too this is not your family
anymore not my circus not my monkeys is
a cousin married if he was married I
would say something if he's single then
no even if he was like these people are
not your problem anymore yeah hi I would
just say no no meow I mean it's also it
does anything this is you know a good
opportunity for an anonymous letter I
love Ron and Sam yeah what do you think
about Sammy coming back to Jersey Shore
I love it I think it's funny I think
it's amazing yeah and Ronnie's not there
right no good Ronnie I'm so tired I
don't know I don't know what's happening
there something are you filming this no
I'm not filming I I have um
they can't afford me good I'm only
kidding no I I haven't been really asked
um but
I think that I think I don't know this
for sure but I know that there's like
something going on with him like coming
back
I mean he has so many problems like
legally personally I don't even come
back full time and I think like I think
maybe I overheard that he was like maybe
filming some scenes or something I don't
know with Sam no I don't think I feel
like she would only agree to come back
if he wasn't there yeah I think that's
the reason that she did are the girlies
on good terms yeah so we work for many
we're never not good charged with her
but she just didn't want to be a part of
it yeah so it'd be nice to come out like
everybody heard everything we went to
like all the I including myself as one
of the girls yeah you are um we invited
her for years to come out to things she
just always kind of ghosted us in lunch
and she started then she unfollowed all
of us and blocked us I mean now she's
now she's back in the thing I think she
just wanted to like Escape I think she
was so uh traumatized from like all that
[__] I mean so many years that's another
thing when you go back and watch it you
realize it was bad Ronnie was like
deeply manipulative and like borderline
abusive to her and like she put up with
so much and like she was just so
vulnerable I could once I rewatched it
as an adult I was like oh there I would
never come back either yeah I can
definitely see that you know how it was
a shock for her but I think now
um
again yeah so I think I think now this
perfect time leave it like she's
fabulous she's gorgeous she's fun she's
gorgeous fabulous she's fun and fabulous
so I think it's a good time for her to
get out there hang out with the girls
you know get get some more you know
exposure for herself and and you know
get some new businesses going whatever
she wants to do with her life but I
think she's she's always been fun and
love and I'm excited to see what happens
with her you're such a media trained
Queen yeah I'm excited to see what the
future holds
okay back to this girl my advice is stay
out of it like don't respond no these
aren't your people anymore you have
absolutely no responsibility to do the
right thing like goodbye even if he is
married and what is vanish mode oh
vanish mode is a thing on Instagram
where like everything vanishes like
Snapchat kind of yeah can they see
screenshots on Instagram now no no good
yeah it's nice I screen grab everything
oh God have you ever screen grabbed and
sentenced to the person you screamed up
from of course and sometimes I'll
Gaslight them and be like look what you
just sent me was that you that just it
was you on Tick Tock was it you no there
was someone at Texas that said what to
do if you do that and like and a great
way to follow up like a great quote to
follow up with to say like why you okay
what was it it was something like oh my
God are you getting my messages because
every yours is coming up like my mind's
mine's coming up as something yeah oh
that's really smart yeah tell me if it's
coming through it's keep saying not to
live it's green on my end or something
that's genius yeah that's better than
mine yeah but I'll just Gaslight people
being like look at that message you just
sent me you're being crazy yeah and it
like doesn't really work read it back to
yourself to see but honestly yeah read
it back but sometimes like you just
gotta own it but like yeah I was talking
[__] yeah like we're having a fight like
I have to vent it is what it is okay
right ready for our third and final to
your toasters yes bring it hey girlie
swirlies I'm writing in so I can stop
being a Naggy [__] girlfriend my
boyfriend has a great group of friends
from college that he keeps in touch with
it's like half girls half boys the only
issue I have is his ex of two years and
is in that friend group and she's
clearly still in love with him I
completely and fully trust him and he
has been nothing but reassuring when I
need it I love him to bits and I know he
loves me too and I wouldn't and he would
never do anything with her regardless I
still find myself just hating this [__]
no matter how much she makes it clear to
her to her that they are just friends I
still feel like she oversteps and
honestly just wish she would find
someone else and move the [__] on I
don't want to let this past relationship
ruin my current one do you have any tips
on how to stop resenting this and the
fact that they remain friends yes
I know it seems hard to seem crazy you
need to go into the lion's den and
become friends with this girl
you have to that's actually really good
advice do you know what I mean yeah he
said first of all you're going to
realize that maybe maybe you'll get some
self-assurance that it's not that you
have to set her try to set her up with
someone else oh I love her out of there
like either like find a new friend and
but she has like you have to become
friends with her because that's going to
take the the worry off you but it's also
keep your enemies closer and you know I
mean closer whatever they say and I
think that'll give you more more peace
of mind
and it also drive him a little crazy so
that might be something fun so if you
get the upper hand that is some of the
best advice first of all yeah I don't
always agree with um keep your friends
close and your enemies closer in this
case I actually do yeah but you know
what is one of those limericks that I
find myself like really resonating With
the Enemy of My Enemy is my friend
when I find out someone wait and think
of your enemy okay then think of your
enemy's enemy
oh that person's your friend oh right
because like you have a mutual enemy
right right whenever I find out that
like someone I know has like the same
enemy as me like I'm automatically like
gravitating I'm like levitating towards
it that's like is that is that same
thing when you like you in the you know
where you're in front of work hate the
same person yes okay yes yes no no it's
not no it's not sorry it's it's more
just once that someone's twice removed
yeah think about it the enemy of my
enemy is my friend okay it's not genius
yeah it's so true what a haiku who's
your anime
um my interceptor
they're literally not okay and you are
so RuPaul you're inner Saboteur they
love to say that on RuPaul are you
watching the season
is it on
no all-stars oh no I'm not oh I'm behind
oh what's up who's on it plus oh is
Kennedy Davenport on it no she's not on
this one this time it's um and then
who's who's left it's um Alexis Michelle
candy Muse Jimbo I [__] love candy I
mean closet just had a storm off she
just quit the show really yes because if
she was being bullied
um who else is on the show this season
um Candy Muse is probably one of my
favorite Queens but she doesn't really
she's not a winner no
she's great though she's amazing
personality yeah her um who else is on
there
you know you have to watch yeah every
time I go to every single event for them
like every single one of them and um I
always want to bring you with you I
don't think you're very very interesting
coming why of course did you see the
Vegas Review show
yeah it was good yeah I went there yeah
it was very good very good okay I will
watch and I would love to come with you
yeah okay well that's Joey on the toes
but you can catch Joey all week long on
your podcast out and about it comes out
every every Wednesday every Friday on
barstowsports.com or anywhere find
podcasts are found and then you also
have your podcast with Snooki which
comes out every Friday it's called it's
happening with Sookie and Joey and we're
fighting podcaster fan you can follow me
at Joey kamasa on all social platforms
I had a very slow start on Tick Tock I'm
still figuring it out but I'm I'm
finding my groove yeah I gotta find my
group you can do like your Glam Glam
does so well on Tick Tock that you can
do like your friends you get ready
comedy shtick while you're doing Glam
yeah I love that I'll figure it out so
follow Joey thank you so much for being
here I love you like any time I know you
will and I would love to have you please
be nice to me toasters they will they
love you did you see the outcrying of
support when you were announced I was
shocked and tell a friend tell a friend
to follow me tell a friend
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcast
anywhere podcasting you found so on
Spotify iTunes Stitcher public radio I
already castbox all the places I listen
to podcasts
good luck talented we are hope you guys
have an amazing day we will see you
tomorrow for a podcast only episode with
Jackie her and I will be recording
remotely and then Friday's episode is in
studio with Jax and Brittany video and
audio you're not going to want to miss
it love you dearly bye